so
i'm curious for both of you
when did you first learn that there was
going to be a spin-off involving your
characters and what were you most
looking forward to exploring as part of
that mingna i'd love to start with you
um i i'm always uh surprised that i've
come as far as i have in my career
because i never i'm always the last to
know so um i just thought i was signing
on as a series regular
for
mandalorian and um i came on set and
found out that i was actually in my own
spin-off project
the book of boba fett
and uh so that was a
a really great surprise and uh i i was
thrilled uh everybody laughed at me but
it was a good laugh
tim didn't though tim
had to set me straight
she was so funny ming didn't realize she
was doing her own series halfway through
the show she goes ah really really oh my
god no wonder the stories were so good
no wonder the stories were so good
yeah but i got a wonderful i had a
wonderful i happened to be in los
angeles at the time uh looking for a job
i think and i was doing the circuit as
we try and do in l.a
and a meeting with john favreau came up
and immediately i thought
this is a good meeting so i got there
three hours early
and uh
dave filoni was there so we had a little
bit of a chat but when i went into their
room i could see the the concept
drawings
and then i started going man
that's me i'm going to be in this so it
was a buzz just to see that and
confirming that they were going to have
me so
john eventually turned up and gave me
the outline this is what we're going to
be doing and i must say he's a man of
his word and everything's come to
fruition in terms of uh the book of boba
fett uh series that we shot
and
yeah and for us we were just dealing to
the you know the
the run of the mill stuff we go to work
and we work hard now with the covert
restrictions so there's no time for
drama tantrums or things like that it's
just all about the work and we had a
wonderful crew a wonderful support unit
so it was just a uh
wonderful opportunity to
to be involved with this whole thing and
again yeah
i don't take anything for granted these
days because uh
our business as you well know it's
always up and down you're in the papers
you're in the magazines one month and
then you're in the fish and chip shop
the next month where people are reading
about you and all the old news so uh
so it's good it's good to be uh
simmering at the moment simmering with
uh heat yeah
and i think
go ahead carly
the good news is i think plenty of
people are talking about the show um
which is great yeah
you know we
worked so hard and we we both
not just us but the entire crew everyone
we all love the show so much so
it's it's nice when the response has
been positive we're very grateful
uh on that note i think i'm actually
already out of time um but thank you so
much for taking the time to sit and chat
about the show it's been great so far
and i i cannot wait to watch the rest of
these episodes because they was anything
you didn't like what did that thank you
carly anything i didn't like i don't
know but i mean i i've loved the dual
flashback you know the past and the
present and and seeing how that's all
going to come together i'm really
looking forward to that so
it's been great thank you very much
thank you so much but um thank you both
for taking the time to chat and i hope
you have a great rest of your day
you